[Music]
foreign
it's no secret in the wealthiest
countries fewer and fewer people want to
have children the falling birth rate is
practically a generalized phenomenon
throughout the developed World it seems
clear that it's going to become one of
the greatest challenges in the very near
future we're talking about countries
that are getting older and have fewer
children in fact most developed
countries are already well below the
replacement rate that is below the 2.1
children per woman of child-bearing age
that would be needed to at least keep
the population stable excluding
immigration of course however there is
one specific case a country in which the
average child per woman is not only
fewer than two children per woman but
less than one we're talking about the
country with the lowest birth rate in
the world and yes as you may have
already guessed if only by the thumbnail
and title of this video I'm talking
about South Korea check it out
specifically we're talking about a
fertility rate of only 0.78 children per
woman in 2022 a level solo that we could
almost say that having children in South
Korea has become an anomaly and take
note because in Seoul this rate is
getting even worse wait for it we're
talking only about 0.59 children per
woman down to almost a quarter of the
replacement rate in other words in this
case it is not that South Korea is going
through a demographic winter it is that
we are practically facing the chronicle
of an Extinction foothold
[Music]
despite being one of the richest and
most advanced countries in the world
South Korea is facing a colossal problem
whose solution is far from simple and
which could cause a demographic
catastrophe in this country as never
seen before a demographic catastrophe
and if things do not change perhaps an
economic one as well even with the
strong robotization of Industry if
things continue as they are it is
possible that in a short time there will
not be enough workers to keep the
economy going it's factories its stores
its schools and businesses of all kinds
and no we're not exaggerating we're not
exaggerating at all take a look at this
graph do you realize what this means
what you are looking at is South Korea's
population projection over the next few
decades as you can see as of today the
land of morning calm may have already
reached its historical maximum
population from now on its population
will not only be much older but it will
also begin to decrease and don't think
it will do so slowly in the next 40
years this country will lose more than
12 million inhabitants that is 25 of its
entire population in demographic terms
that's a huge drop in population and
that's not all by the end of the century
if the current Trend continues South
Korea's population is expected to shrink
to less than half from today's almost 52
million inhabitants to just over 20
million there is no other country in the
world with such a poor Outlook we're
talking about a scenario in which not
only South Koreans may end up
disappearing but a lot of wealth could
be destroyed in the process meaning that
those remaining will face enormous
hardship
foreign think about it if the forecasts
come true many of the children being
born today will see their country with
half the population when they retire
with all that implies more social
spending less savings less consumption
and so on and so forth and keep in mind
we are not talking about a vague
hypothesis but about a process that has
already begun after years with an
absolutely plummeting birth rate there
are already many cases in the country of
primary schools obstetric and pediatric
hospitals and services that are having
to close
now many of you may be wondering at this
point why on Earth is this happening in
a country where the economy is
supposedly booming and people are not
lacking anything what exactly are the
reasons why South Koreans no longer want
to have children what is the government
doing to reverse this situation does it
have a solution well in this video we're
going to answer these and more questions
so pay attention because this is the
story of the country that is running
towards its own Extinction
the four knows
[Music]
as you can imagine a disaster like the
one we are describing is not something
that just happens there are reasons and
they are neither few nor easy to explain
but here on visualpolitik we're going to
try to tell you about it in the most
summarized way possible you see the
easiest thing to do would be to blame it
on low wages hyper competitiveness in
South Korea all that women prefer to
focus on their careers rather than put
them at risk to have children but no
although these factors are partly to
blame they do not explain why South
Korea is the country with the lowest
birth rate in the world after all these
factors apply elsewhere as well so what
on Earth has caused the problem in South
Korea to reach such a magnitude
foreign
well I can tell you in advance that some
things will shock you a lot on the one
hand South Korean Society is perhaps one
of the most conservative and traditional
of all developed countries and okay yes
I know what you're thinking but Josh
conservative societies usually have an
advantage when it comes to birth rates
don't they well no not always one of the
problems that they have in the land of
the morning calm is their extremely
puritanical and traditional way of
understanding motherhood and family
models in fact there is virtually only
one family model the one formerly
composed between a woman and a man and
then the children of course anything
outside of this framework is effectively
left out of the system and South Korean
Society loses a lot of opportunities to
solve or at least mitigate its major
childlessness problem but as I know that
what I have said may be surprising and
that some of you are probably even
shocked we're going to give you data and
concrete examples
for example in South Korea only 2.9 of
babies born in 2021 were born out of
wedlock while the oecd average is wait
for it 40 16 times higher nearly 40 of
children in South Korea are simply not
born in other words in South Korean
Society it's inconceivable to have
children without a traditional marriage
being married is a prerequisite for
having children and no it is not that
they are religiously or socially very
different or that they have more
appetite for marriage which I already
told you they do not it is a matter
above all a cultural one
in the case of single mothers for
example many face the Judgment of a
society in which honor and what people
will say still carry a lot of weight and
what can I say in South Korea having a
child out of wedlock is frowned upon and
let's not even talk about same-sex
families in general all these things are
considered bad for children in this
country and while children in the rest
of the developed world don't appear to
be turning out so badly in this video
we're not going to debate family
structures what we care about here is
the impact this rigid attitude has on
birth rates
[Applause]
the fact is that all this cultural
pressure forces women to make a choice
to look for a husband at all costs in
order to have children or to forego
motherhood and focus on themselves and
their professional careers and yes this
is exactly what many women are doing
choosing this second option will tell
you why in more detail later but the
fact is that in the end fewer and fewer
women are willing to have children which
logically contributes to the fact that
the birth rate is at rock bottom but
wait a minute because that is not all
bad news fortunately Society is also
changing and little by little more and
more people are accepting motherhood
outside of traditional marriage for
example in the 10 years between 2012 and
2022 acceptance of single motherhood has
grown by more than 12 points from just
over 22 percent to nearly 35 percent of
respondents of course public
institutions are still slobber at making
progress for example the South Korean
mother and child health acts Definition
of sub-fertility explicitly refers to a
married couple that is there is no other
possibility for receiving fertility
treatment support one way or another the
system excludes single women from access
to fertility or in vitro fertilization
treatments
what's more the South Korean bioethics
and safety act says that anyone seeking
to perform IVF treatment must have the
consent of their partner in other words
it is taken for granted that these
treatments are exclusively for couples
which means that in South Korea it is in
practice impossible for a woman alone to
have access to them and not only that
apart from what the law itself says the
South Korean church is also fervently
opposed to these techniques for
unmarried women keep in mind we're
talking about a country where the
relationship between politicians and
religious congregations is usually very
close
and visualpolitik viewers all this
becomes even more important if we take
into account another problem that young
South Korean women today do not want to
deal with basically the traditional
roles that still exist in South Korean
Society regarding motherhood and
marriage
you could say that the professional and
personal Ambitions of young women in
this country have changed much faster
than the perception of their role in
society for example it is very very
common in South Korea for men to leave
the burden of raising children to women
even if the woman Works in South Korea
children are strictly women's business
and logically this is not easy to
reconcile with Modern Life and the
legitimate personal and professional
aspirations of hundreds and thousands
millions of women it's something we've
told you many times on visualpolitik
narratives count and no we're not
talking about hetero patriarchy or
anything like that but about social
roles that in the vast majority of the
West have already been overcome but the
same has not happened in South Korea nor
in Asia in general and then of course
there is also the issue of salaries the
desire for careers and extremely
expensive housing something we talked
about in previous videos
well the fact is that the sum of all
these reasons has led more and more
young women to feel that marriage and
motherhood are an unnecessary burden or
rather a problem that they have no
desire to face you want an eye-popping
fact according to me 2020 survey 42.5 of
South Koreans in their 30s were not
married 13 points higher and in 2020.
real man's booming in South Korea but
marriage no longer the end game in fact
of all households in South Korea as many
as four out of 10 are single person
households and 2022 saw the lowest
number of marriages since 1970 with
fewer than 192 000 in South Korea young
women are less and less willing to get
married and take on all that this
entails in the culture and Society of
this country and you have already seen
that without marriage There Are No
Children either or at least there are
much fewer of them what's more divorce
is also a taboo in Korean Society
despite being legal many women who
divorce face some form of discrimination
although it is becoming more socially
accepted thanks to contemporary Korean
TV series and films that means that a
woman is acutely aware that if she gets
married she could have a hard time after
divorce if things go wrong and this of
course makes many of them even more
hesitant to get married nowadays but
there's more
as much of this may surprise you it is
even a women's movement known as the
four gnomes no dating no sex with men no
marriage no children the traditional
family is becoming less and less popular
among young people in this country and
as you can see the way things are set up
has consequences but at this point and
now that you know what the main causes
of this demographic debacle are many of
you may be asking yourselves a question
what on Earth is the government doing to
try to solve this situation can it do
anything well the truth is that yes they
have done and continue to do things but
you could say that basically it seems as
if they were desperately trying to do
things blindly you want to hear what is
probably the funniest part of this whole
story well pay close attention
[Music]
killing flies with cannons
let me ask you a question what if I told
you that South Korea has squandered 200
billion dollars over the last 16 years
on policies to encourage birth rates and
yet they have achieved absolutely
nothing at all 20 billion dollars later
the number of births is at historic lows
which by the way is a warning to all
those politicians who think that this
matter can be solved with a checkbook it
turns out the South Korean state has
squandered some 12.5 billion dollars
every year on birth rate management
policies this is more or less the budget
that a country like Spain allocates to
defense annually and as you can see the
result has been zilch nada nothing could
it be that South Korea is the perfect
example of how the birth rate cannot be
encouraged with public money well maybe
yes maybe we are facing the wildest
example we could see but that's not the
worst of it the worst is that the
government continues to opt for this
path despite admitting that it does not
work career to Triple baby payments
after its smashes own record for world's
lowest fertility rate to give you an
idea president Yoon has announced that
he would triple the baby check already
in place for the first two years of a
newborn's life this is an increase from
the 300 000 won set by former president
Moon in to 1 million one which is
slightly more than 750 dollars per month
and let's not fool ourselves the result
will probably not change anything
in rich countries like South Korea
having or not having children has more
to do with social and cultural factors
and less to do with economic problems if
the environment is right and when people
feel they are protected and encouraged
to have children they will have babies
even if they are told not to cash
incentives alone can't really make much
progress in boosting child's births June
social welfare professor at iwa Women's
University of course the truth is that
even this measure probably as useless as
the previous one is better than other
crazy ideas that South Korean
politicians have come up with to deal
with this problem some of them are so
crazy that anyone would think they are
desperate just grasping a straws you
don't believe us you think we're
exaggerating well take note
[Music]
some time ago for example a dozen
legislators put forward a proposal to
flood the country with foreign nannies
paid below minimum wage in fact the
proposal included waiving the minimum
wage for foreign nannies this is
something that has already been done in
countries such as Singapore under the
excuse that conditions are still much
better than in their home countries
nevertheless it is something that raised
a lot of criticism in South Korea
then there was also a proposal to exempt
men who have three or more children
before the age of 30 from compulsory
military service the problem is that men
are the only ones who are obliged to do
military service and what can I tell you
no matter how many men are willing to
get rid of the Annoying military service
in this way if there are no women
willing to have children it's a useless
measure but wait a minute because now
comes the really good parts
[Music]
the two things I'm about to tell you now
have come true this is not a joke check
it out South Korea Pools website mapping
women of prime age to have children
South Korea has closed a government
website showing the number of women aged
between 15 and 49 of childbearing age by
City District and region after a public
outcry users could look up how many
women between those ages resided in the
neighborhood for the past 10 years it's
kind of like farmer wants a wife except
strictly online and where the women have
no idea they've been selected for the
show and no one even asked them if I
they wanted to get married not to worry
though it's promoted by the government
don't you think it's brilliant anyway
well if that has caught your attention
you ain't seen nothing yet in South
Korea there are local governments that
have been subsidizing the purchase of
foreign wives yeah yeah that's exactly
what I said South Korea's local
subsidies encourage foreign braid buying
raids from Uzbekistan most expensive
more than 35 Municipal governments have
implemented bylaws providing marriage
subsidies to local Men Who tie the knot
with foreign braids we're talking about
a whole mail order bride industry that
has been around for a few years now in
Korea
seems to have really taken off even in
Seoul itself there are numerous
establishments businesses where you can
go choose a woman from a catalog and
then after paying a certain fee these
companies arrange for these women to fly
to South Korea to marry you obviously
not in a forced way but even so pretty
crazy South Korea is along with Taiwan
the Asian country where this practice is
most common for some this is a clear
example of human trafficking but for
others it is nothing more than an
intermediation like any other in fact
this type of activity has a name they're
actually called marriage Brokers and
take note there are almost 400 of them
throughout the country and I don't know
what do you want me to say moral
considerations aside perhaps the fact
that there are public administrations
subsidizing these operations with up to
almost ten thousand dollars crosses all
lines and yes that is exactly what some
municipalities do the result you can see
it perfectly in this graph
be there as it may as you have seen
South Korea has a birth rate problem so
severe that it may put the country
itself on the road to its own Extinction
a problem that far from improving is
only getting worse more and more women
are rejecting motherhood and marriage
and that in a society and under
institutions that are still unable to
accept other types of motherhood or
familial roles and adapt public policies
is a serious problem but at this point
it is your turn do you think South Korea
could reverse its enormous demographic
problem with other kinds of public
policies has the old model of believing
that to have children you just need to
give away more and more money failed
what do you think of the proposals and
policies that are being promoted in
South Korea to get more children born
leave us your opinion Below in the
comments and remember if you like this
video don't forget to like it subscribe
to our Channel and hit the little bell
so you don't miss any important news
coming soon oh and very important if you
want to help us to keep growing and
improving you can actually join our
community on patreon to receive
exclusive content I'll leave you a link
in the description once again thank you
so very much for being there all the
best see you next time